SPEAKER: For data
scientists, Jupyter notebooks
is a de facto tool for
performing rapid data analysis.
And you might have seen
in our previous videos
that Kubeflow deployments
include services for spotting
and managing Jupyter notebooks.
Let's take a look at
what a notebook can do
and how to set one up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you want to check out
the documentation directly,
check out the link below to
read more about setting up
notebooks on Kubeflow.
Notebooks on Kubeflow
are a great place
to start with Kubeflow.
You can take a smaller data set,
train it, and serve your model
using notebooks.
While you could run a
Jupyter notebook locally,
there are some amazing benefits
that Kubeflow-hosted notebooks
give you, namely, you
have better integration
with other Kubeflow components.
In other words
notebooks integrate well
with the rest of the
infrastructure for things
like accessing other services
in the Kubeflow cluster
via their cluster IP addresses.
They also integrate with access
control and authentication.
Administrators can set up
standard role-based access
for the entire
organization, providing
consistent and
centralized security.
Secondly, it's easy
to share notebooks
across the organization and
configure who can access them
because you can deploy them on
pods in a Kubernetes cluster.
Plus, a lot of common
libraries come preloaded
in the default notebook image.
For example, it
includes all the plugins
that you need to train a
TensorFlow model with Jupyter,
including TensorBoard for rich
visualizations and insights
into your model.
And lastly, you can leverage
the power of customized compute
shapes and GPUs for
machine learning
that's compute intensive.
With notebooks on Kubeflow,
you're hosting your notebook
on a Kubernetes pod.
You can setup as
many notebook servers
as you like in each
Kubeflow deployment.
Each notebook server can
have multiple notebooks.
And each notebook belongs
to one Kubernetes namespace,
which matches a
project or a team name.
A user can then
configure who can access
their individual namespace.
Let's walk through a setup of
a Jupyter notebook on Kubeflow.
In the Kubeflow UI,
click Notebook Servers
in the left-hand panel.
Choose the namespace
corresponding
to your Kubeflow profile.
Click New Server to
create a notebook server.
You should see a
page for entering
details of your new server.
Enter a name of your choice
for the notebook server.
Select a Docker image for
the baseline deployment
of your notebook server.
You can choose from a
range of standard images
or specify a custom image.
You can keep the
default CPU allocation.
But for CPU-intensive jobs, you
can choose more than one CPU.
Choose the total amount of
memory for your notebook
server.
Finally, by default,
Kubeflow provisions
a Kubernetes
persistent volume, PV,
for each of the your data
volumes with 10 gigabytes.
But you can also configure
your own and specify it here.
This is to hold your personal
workspace for this notebook
server.
That way, you can
retain data even if you
destroy your notebook server.
Click Launch.
You should see an entry for
your new notebook server
on the Notebook Servers page
with a spinning indicator
in the Status column.
It can take a few minutes to
set up the notebook server.
When the server
provisioning is complete,
you should see an
entry for your server
on the Notebook Servers page
with a checkmark in the Status
column.
Next, you can click Connect
to start the notebook server.
Click Upload to upload
an existing notebook.
But let's go ahead and create
an empty Python 3 notebook.
To test our Jupyter
installation,
we'll run a basic "Hello World"
program, a very simple MNIST
classifier which uses
image recognition
to classify handwritten digits.
And we get an accuracy
of 0.9016 back.
There you have it,
notebooks on Kubeflow.
It gives you the
same experience you
love about Jupyter notebooks
with the added benefits
of image extensibility,
scalability,
access control, sharing and
submitting jobs directly
on your Kubernetes cluster.
It's the easiest way for
you to immediately start
experimenting on Kubeflow.
You can read more
about notebooks
on Kubeflow in the link below.
And stay tuned for
the next episode.
[MUSIC PLAYING]